welcome to this video you playing
Carlton yeah not Magnus skies from
Turkey actually and name nope ok so the
Slav the ever-popular sloth defense hmm
yeah let's allow the main line and see
if he goes for that yep he does hmm what
about this can I do something else there
I recently saw that they sometimes play
this gambit stuff here let's try for
this it's interesting of course a 4s the
normal move but this is an interesting
tribe ok so he doesn't really try to
keep the pawn with be 5y you really
cannot play b5 and Bishop f5 that's
usually not a good idea so he just seems
to return this pawn which is very nice
now for me because getting this pawn
back without having none without having
them spend a moose on a 4 which is also
quite a weakening move ok quit be three
I don't know queen bee three it's good
could be interesting he has Knight b6
but I have night 85 which I thought was
an interesting idea let's try that it's
a bit unconventional but interesting
just attacking b7 rugby 8 is bad due to
Bishop f4
27 probably and then my idea was evil
and possibly d5 very direct way to play
that's probably not bad for black but it
set some interesting problems okay so II
for our oh I wonder they're all so I did
a very concrete ways to play based on
maybe night taking on b7 or c6 but
doesn't seem to work so let's play this
that looks very normal and our Bishop f4
I am Bishop f4 and then look the one
next meal that looks good look fd1 or
look 81 one of the one of the eternal
questions in chess which look let's do
this it's impossible to determine really
in a blitz game it's even difficult to
do in a normal time control game but in
a blitz game just have to have to go for
it sometimes um okay so um bishop age
three Sosa move know which Hank c4 so
play play a normal one is still slightly
slightly tired to be seven cannot go t
five okay play a small waiting move and
see what is doing next it's running out
of let's say a schematic moves Bishop fa
de maybe something like that but and
then that he cannot move much
c5 it's not working if I've it's not
working it's hard to move any piece on
yeah I have to do something like that ok
so I cannot go d5 yeah may I can but
it's probably not leading to much hmm
not quite sure how to continue okay yeah
I'm bill Bishop c7 I am planning if I
yellow let's go e5 then yep be 70 is
hanging
yeah what else okay so let's check I can
really take be 70 yeah night c5 is a
very important move then I always have
let's say Bishop b5 95 keeping the pawn
or in this case even blundering a piece
o I'm really just winning this I believe
yeah I mean you can play that position
and just hope for the best rugby aid or
something but both nights d6 oh that
looks weakening mmm well it takes Bishop
d3 yeah okay but I can go here yeah
let's just see this looks finer or off
to d6 yeah yes night f4 but 96 looks
very strong even if it gives away in
exchange yeah like night f 496 is really
terrible we can play 92 but I don't
really mind that much that's possibly
not even the best continuation let's
check them to something better that
something that does not give away they
exchange Queen you three this Bishop b5
it's also good but ok really the
exchange is not not important
yeah look rib sorry bishop t6ed six
check okay
yeah night see if not see one look see
one this is just a fantastic position
with the pawn on d6 it's more than
enough for the exchange now I have no
other more briefly thinking maybe t7 or
something but the Queen was just saying
so yeah okay so he moves the night I can
just take for a simple solution yeah
let's do that and keep it simple and
Queen a form which makes c6 collapse now
you cannot move it as the Queen hangs
and the Bishop Bishop is protecting the
pawn on d6 i will just win the c6 pawn
and the pawn is just too strong down on
the d file
yeah but if I go here I'm after Queen D
6 i'm winning a whole book on the aid i
know so yeah yeah I overlooked this pin
down let's spit it's bad time warning
that was stupid young I was really
stupid hmm this is unprotected what what
wooden not what an idiotic idea okay so
how do i play now that was that was
really bad look here or something I
don't know that was rad yeah from this
super great position check yeah I don't
really know what to do it was really
like was really completely outplayed and
now things are far from far from clear
nice playing quite well he end the
defense now I have pretty good control
there but it doesn't look like i should
win
I could've taken the rook game Draw just
about to resign okay ah what a howler it
was a very nice game actually with the
added totally forgot that the rukon c1
is unprotected yeah you know you're not
winning this is kind of kind of
heartbreaking yeah you can also just
take f1 play 96 but ok this is you're
just totally winning so it's really no
need to improve on that so what is how
do i improve here yeah I just forgot
that the rukon c1 is unprotected and I'm
giving away my all important pawn if I
take with the book it's probably just
over that's just over you cannot take c6
Bishop see six wins the rock now and
what exactly is his move I mean he
doesn't really have any move let's say
zero move here I think now I can even
take them this seems like a win yeah I
get to d7 cheeky 5 and promote yeah
totally useless man this is just
terrible this is a terrible idea and I
don't have any way to harasses King that
I was thinking this may be at first like
hey and trying to enter but I mean this
is not threatening anything and this is
a much much more problem
check not really sure if this is this a
draw am I really worse here yeah maybe I
should just take you from but ok it was
a matter of playing quick moves and not
so much about quality yeah yeah that was
bad an interesting point in the opening
is that here after g3 what he did I
think is just a bad setup you should
really try to keep the pawn to b5 if you
don't do that if you just return the
pawn it is simply a good position for
white because I will get in efore
ultimately and have a good central
control yeah the in the Slav this D
takes e4 line the real idea of it is
that white only gets the porn back um in
cases where a 4 has to be played as it
is normal on move 5 and with a form
Black has a compensation in terms of the
wicked queen side and the square on
before with the Buddha ponder on a phone
but without the pawn move white is just
dominating in the center this is just a
bad position yeah in the sloth you do
you play this move d takes you for
really for very specific reasons that
capturing away from the center and the
reason is that why it is usually either
sacrificing upon or playing a 4 ok you
can play III and get the pong back but
this is also yeah this is losing time so
black has a concrete compensation for
for all of that but in most cases a 4 is
played and if we compare this yeah like
a like to the game then if we compare
this here it takes a long time for white
to even get you fall in and in
in my game yeah I just could fianchetto
which supports the the e4 push and they
even could play it in one move so here
this is just just nice for white black
has no compensation whatsoever for his
leg in space yeah but it didn't help
yeah first game of a session as usual a
tricky business thanks for watching